ladies and gentlemen Bill Murray
I know she does
yeah
well it's finally happening on May 20th
David Letterman is gonna hang up his
jersey and retire from the talking to
celebrities at 11:30 on weeknights game
yeah we'll have to see how Stephen
Colbert adapts when he takes over the
late-night mantle in September but there
was a time in late night when no one was
better than Dave and we put together a
cut of some of his best moments check it
out
and in this clip I think we're going to
see you know what let's look at it we'll
talk about it later and Joaquin I'm
sorry you couldn't be here tonight we
owe an apology to Farrah Fawcett
I'm strong you want to arm a hog taking
know I take before you start mine I can
I can I can kick
we're going to station identification
get the hose
why are we laughing not sure I thought
that I would never want to do this show
with you wha-wha because you thought I
was uh yeah I just kiss up to everybody
on your show now I can suspend that
behavior tonight if you like you're not
irritated at all I know this is
irritating me okay good
are you trying to no I'm not trying to
irritate you actually you do irritate me
sometimes well you kind of irritated me
too really uh how'd you like being in
jail
I guess the food was just awful wasn't
it yes yeah well not supposed to be got
its channel so what was dinner usually
um like jail mystery meat I have no idea
I've moved on with my life so I don't
really want to talk about it anyway what
is it you did do you know what you did
love you too
yeah yeah somebody you met in prison oh
I smell fish sticks
get yourself a gallon ireli and a gallon
of mayo a little something the boys at
late-night R & D have been fooling
around with we call it sky bowling here
we are this is a Len Lucas we're going
into Len Lucas's office of New York
my name is Len Lucas I am an NBC
executive I'm not wearing pants repeat I
am not wearing pants
well can you see the
you sir in the blue blazer I need some
hot dogs five hot dogs go right up to
the stand I'll pay you back
two with onions two with kraut you look
wonderful in stripes have you been
dieting this is my last time wearing a
fancy dress on a talk show and
conforming to gender norms out of
respect for you I my gift to is I want
to give you the dress you can keep it
I get emotional just like punch me just
punch me or something 20 years ago was
my first part I did stand-up right there
say David they've liked what he saw he
wants to try to develop a sitcom for you
and that sitcom became Everybody Loves
Raymond yeah so anyways I just like to
say I know that mr. Letterman is not for
the sentimental but I say I'm sure I
love you thank you thank you for
everything they like every kid who grew
up watching him we'll miss him
dave is the best and you should see him
and uh which one more
David Letterman I love you and I thank
you for all of the joy and the laughs
and the intelligence you have brought to
us for 33 years
like if you're gonna miss Dave and leave
a comment from what your favorite
Letterman moment was over the years if
you don't remember Letterman leave a
comment anyway telling us how you can't
wait to grow up subscribe for more
awesome hashtag news clips and pop
culture nuggets
I'm Gabe ho writer and a similar thing
happened to me with the whole drew
Barrymore flashing thing I got flashed
by a guy named drew it was an alright
birthday